uh former vice president joe biden is
accusing president trump of being
up to no good saying this and i quote
this president is going to try to
indirectly steal the election by arguing
that mail and ballots don't work
they're not real they're not fair well
let's talk about it martha as you well
know we're
almost 100 days off from the election
and six weeks from now
voters will begin to cast their ballots
you know a lot about voting i'm sure
why is vote by mail such a bad thing
when it's what republicans and some
democrats have always urged
americans to do that is to get their
ballots in early so that
people can you know just get it out of
the way for election day
well you know i would go back donna to
the night that you and i spent at the
iowa caucuses
waiting for those decisions to come in
and the difficulty with the software on
the app
and you move forward into a very
difficult primary season where there
were problems in california
uh there was also of course everything
got pushed back from the primaries
so the likelihood that we're going to
have an extremely complicated election
night that might turn into an election
week or potentially even longer than
that
i think is pretty good um so on that
layer i think there's legitimacy
in questioning how this is all going to
work we've never done an election in the
middle of a pandemic like this
and that's uncharted territory i think
there's good reason to be concerned on
the other hand
you've got very strong rhetoric coming
from joe biden
this week calling the president a racist
and now saying that he's going to
indirectly try to steal the election
and one of the things just politically
as an observer i see in that
is that he's sensing this shift that is
happening right now in the trump
campaign there's a more realistic tone
that has come into uh the campaign with
regard to the virus
they have a new campaign manager they've
instituted these daily briefings there's
there's a
sort of a palpable shift and very tough
to maintain the kind of lead that joe
biden has right now and i think he
senses that it's time to sort of
you know go go for the gut uh in this
moment
to make sure that he can try to hold on
to and keep that lead strong
well katie uh you know as someone who
knows a little bit about grassroot
politics and understand the political
landscape what can state and local
officials do
to ensure the integrity of our elections
as you well know we have a decentralized
form of government
which means that our elections are held
at the state and local level it's not
a federal election it is held
technically at the state and local level
so what can they do
that is true which is why the claims of
russians hacking the
national election were ridiculous in the
first place but you're right these
things do take place
at the local level they've been getting
ready for the presidential election
since the last presidential election
that we saw and they can institute the
same social distancing measures that
they are instituting in schools locally
that they are
they've instituted for months at places
like grocery stores
and in terms of mail-in ballots if they
really want to go to that kind of model
and send
registered voters mail-in ballots to
return well they better make sure that
their voter rolls are cleaned up meaning
that they don't have people who have
passed on
or moved still on those on those roles
because especially if you don't have any
kind of voter id or verification system
then that causes all kinds of problems
and we've seen just recently in local
elections
you have mail-in ballots being changed
from democrat to republican this doesn't
just affect republicans
you have hundreds of ballots going
uncounted and now you have the post
office saying
well this is going to be a problem
because there's going to be an influx of
mail and a delay and so
you know there are many many issues in
many instances and examples of fraud
when it comes to mass vote in ballots
which is why the president is concerned
about it
well you know you and i can talk about
russian hacking attempts in our state
election systems at another time but
gray do you think the postal service
can ramp up uh before november to uh
make sure that these ballots are not
only
uh processed and given to the election
officials to count
especially given the fact that the post
office might be running out of money
come september
wait a second the post office is running
out of money
i thought they were expertly efficiently
run
somebody maybe that should tell us
something about the post
the the posters look i am i'm for
uh mail-in voting because i'm uh
naturally lazy
i don't like to wait in lines i think
it's a good thing i think we don't
i don't think we want to like completely
demonize this thing because i don't i
i i it helps everybody so maybe maybe
just a closer eye
i'm more worried about joe i mean every
thought in his head these days
is not his own it's like he said he's
he's just a slobbering echo of something
you already heard so you heard this
story
but like weeks before and now it's
coming to him he's like a really bad
parrot that repeats stuff that he hears
on grandma's radio
you know he just like and he just keeps
repeating it and he doesn't really have
any original thoughts so i think i'd be
i'm okay i am looking forward to the
debate
that's what i want and i want to ask you
donna is there going to be one
is there going to be a debate in fact
in fact greg there will be three three
debates so you'll have a great
opportunity to
have a wonderful night of popcorn beer
and wine
hey jesse how do you intend to vote this
fall are you going to vote by mail
are you going to stand in line or just
tell me what what's your plan have you
made plans yet
um i don't discuss who i vote for and
how donna that is a uh
that's a sacred might of mine as an
american citizen so if anybody i'm not
sharing it with you
either uh are you planning to vote let
me just ask that question
will you vote this fall jesse yes i will
vote as much as i can
no that's illegal
[Applause]
i'm not getting the post office involved
you know what i mean like
anybody who thinks getting the postal
service involved in an election hasn't
been paying much attention to the postal
service
go to a post office one day or send
something into the mail
and see how long it takes to get there i
want to know who won the election
the night of the election i don't want
to have to wait to december to find out
trump won
well uh let me just say this we may not
know the night the night of the election
but we'll
figure it out i love the post office did
you see what the post office said in
this memo
they said you know we may see mail get
left behind or on the work room floor or
on the docks which is not typical
that's what they're saying already
that's why we need to provide them with
the resources